j'aimerais d'ailleurs précisé juste une
chose si vous me permettez c'est très
important je veux d'abord avoir une
pensée pour arriver à bille tendance à
faire c'est pas mon client mais il est
quand même protégé par la présomption
d'innocence alors vous êtes là vous êtes
le voit chez l'avocat de la victime mère
du tout mais je veux dire oui d'abord et
avant tout je me suis habitants
bénéficient de la présomption
d'innocence on peut chaque jeu tant d
autres comme ça très important quand
bien même je suis l'avocat de la victime
oui d'autant plus d'ailleurs parce que
je crois au droit oui bon disons victime
dit pas présumées victimes au nom cyrill
régnante on est victimes quand on dépose
une plainte et quand on est quand on a
des idées t et quand on a un préjudice
physique et moral après pour qu'il y ait
un lien de causalité pour dire que c'est
ce monsieur qui a commis cet acte c'est
autre chose d'accord ma cliente
s'avérait puisque ça a chuté de partout
elle effectivement victime qu'est ce qui
s'est passé selon le pilote sauce que
vous pouvez vous imaginez bien que je
sais pas sur votre plateau que je veux
dire les choses mais ça sera aux juges
d'instruction que je donnerai tous les
éléments mais j'ai
elles voulaient pas porter plainte et la
base de la série le sud macouria dans
les lianes plainte qui a été déposée il
ya pas deux il n'y a pas de mains
courantes d'accord c'est la déposer une
plante c'est une plainte qui a été
déposée le soir même d'accord voilà
pourquoi ne faut pas qu'on a fabuleux
sur cette affaire mais c'est parce qu'on
avait dit oui alors c'est parce qu'on
avait dit donc c'est bien le dit jean in
tout le reste ensuite est soumis au
secret de l'instruction le juge
d'instruction va instruire à charge et à
décharge ma cliente apporte des éléments
la partie adverse va apporter des
éléments nous allons débattre
contradictoirement comme dans un pays
serein apaisé votre clientèle aurait
préféré que ça ne sorte pas dans
l'immédiat une croisière sur parce que
ma cliente pour une raison très simple
son nom
n'a pas été divulgué mais elle ne le
souhaite pas elle reste elle souhaite
rester anonyme c'est son droit le plus
cher notre j'ai entendu par ci par là
qu'elle avait des intérêts que cela tout
ça ce sont des foutaises ma cliente
c'est une femme extrêmement simple c'est
une jeune femme pour qui j'ai un immense
respect immense estime que je salue une
très grande dignité
il y à travers cette femme je pense à
toutes les femmes victimes
je les dis d'ailleurs ici sur ce plateau
j'étais à la place de yann moix je
l'avais dit mon combat le plus cher
c'est la défense
des femmes victimes de violence toutes
les sortes de violences c'est pour ça
que j'ai prêté sa voix car vous nous
dire de la sphère l avance le fait est
là dans sa sphère l avance très bien ça
va être jugé qu'au nom mais d'abord il
faut qu'à une instruction d'accord on
est en instruction à partir du moment où
les habitants a été justement là là là
il est il est 15h en examen pour viol ça
peut durer combien de temps cette
affaire entre 12 mois et 18 mois voilà
donc pendant 12 mois du mois dont carey
habitants il sait comment il ya un
contrôle judiciaire oui mais bon oui
mais oui mais médiatiquement
personne va faire appel à lui c'est
marrant c'est drôle madame mayer parce
que lorsque je suis venu voir ya six
mois et dix mois là vous avez une pensée
pour les habitants mais l'autre jour
vous aviez une pensée pour la victime
supposée victime jeudi que j'imagine que
pour sa vie professionnelle ce sera le
bon ticket mais c'est pas mon problème
non mais je les sens et d'avant j'ai pas
aimerait bien et puis c'est d'abord dire
comment votre cliente au préalable a
nommé l'avouer ce format vous tomber
dessus et vous avez parlé de la 3g en
suivant très important celui marie juste
que c'est un fait que sa carrière est
effectivement comme nous on parle
souvent les affaires raison que voilà on
dit l'une a tué régnant sur ce point
vous avez raison voilà les c'est bien
sûr sur ce point vous avez absolument
raison le problème c'est qu'il est
médiatiquement connu bien sûr on est
dans ce problème là et qui élancent la
mèche ces sont les médias parce que ma
clientèle n'a jamais divulguer quoi que
ce soit le problème et je vous dis on
c'est un secret de polichinelle c'est
que lorsque quelqu'un dépose une plainte
dans un commissariat de police sa fuite
souvent mais s'il ya souvent des
relations entre les fonctions de police
entre des journalistes c'est tout moi je
les bus dont je l' ai vu dans des
dossiers notamment quand j'étais
l'avocat de pete doherty d'un coup
toutes les trente secondes puis de
retrouver une information qui sortait au
début une information qui sortait toutes
les 30 secondes c'était je vous assure
très lourd et extrêmement pesant
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui le dossier il
est lourd de ses deux clientes ou bien
vous
non c'est un deux un dossier ou où vous
avez une femme qui est considéré
victimes d'accord et elle demande
auprès de la justice qu'elle soit
reconnue ce qu'elle a le dre justice
d'accord c'est tout et que ça soit fait
de façon très sereine si je suis venu
sur votre plateau juste pour vous dire
ça pour vous dire voilà c'est qu'elle
n'a pas voulu être médiatisée du nord
elle veut pas et c'est tout elle veut
pas parce que ce n'est pas son internet
médiatisé général et l'état aujourd'hui
et les traumatisés et les victimes et la
lamal physiquement elle a mal moralement
et à la peur aussi qu'on sache
qui s'est vidé le gala pour bien sûr
mais c'est normal mais ce qui prouve ce
qui prouve sa bonne foi c'est que voilà
elle se confie auprès de la justice pour
que ça se passe bien et que ça soit bien
diligentée